no okay stop she's using nothing to pick
those she's not using a lock pitch she's
she's just pulling at them and then they
come off hey guys i'm matt johnson and
i'm an escape artist for about 30 years
now today you and i are going to be
looking at movie and tv escapes and
we're going to be judging how real they
actually are
back in phillips's car why
they think we're idiots
picking instead of handcuffs escape is
used all the time by escape artists
these are standard
police regulation handcuffs here
probably double lock-in so when you put
them on
if you don't double lock it the ratchet
can still push in and could cause a lot
of pain that to me looks like a blade
from a hacksaw or something you could
use that to to get out of handcuffs
there are three ways to get out of
handcuffs that i know of one is with a
key
you could actually get out of a pair of
handcuffs
by fashioning a key with something like
a paperclip and then a third way is
what's called a shim uh which is a flat
piece of steel
um which he he's using here he's putting
it between the cuff and the ratchet is
sliding it in there and essentially
where this goes in here you can see that
little space where it goes in well if i
lock that those teeth are hidden a
little lever here that's got teeth on it
which is which he sprung right so when
you push that in that little lever goes
click click click click like that but
because the teeth are serrated one way
now i can't pull it back out
so if i put a flat piece of metal in
that hole
and push it in
and then just push the cuff in one time
it'll then slide out because the the
flat piece of metal is between the
serrated teeth and the little ratchet
he's in the back of a police car he's
stressing out probably but what you have
to do as an escape artist you have to
lower your heart rate calm your nerves
and just focus on the job at hand i mean
it looks pretty calm he's taking him 10
seconds or so to get out i mean you can
get out of handcuffs a lot faster than
that the record is a guy
from italy called the lexus arts in
0.9 seconds however when you put in
things like they're behind your back so
you've got to find where you're at plus
he's jammed up against the seat and seat
belted in he hasn't got a lot of room
right so i would actually say 10 seconds
in that situation under duress is
actually pretty fast i would actually
give this a high 9 or a 10.
let's try and get
if indy moved his left arm even a little
bit more that thing would slide right
off his shoulder i would have personally
liked to have seen in this like when
houdini did the 100-foot rope tie
challenge he'd be on a chair just like
this but the rope would be wrapped
around his neck and under his arms and
through his legs rope escapes as a rule
require a lot more pure strength than
say doing a handcuff escape right
because a hank of escape is really not
using strength using dexterity you've
got to manipulate your body to get out
of a rope or something like that what am
i looking for
my lucky charm
try and burn through the ropes
i don't know how you get in your hand
from here up to that rope i don't know
how fast uh that fire is going to burn
through that rope i've done upside down
straight jacket escapes where i've had
the rope on fire and you know i'm 220
pounds hanging upside down there's a lot
of weight on that rope it takes a while
for that rope to burn through it depends
what kind of rope it is as well if you
go to like a a hardware store and buy
rope a lot of it is um it's like a
plastic the fibers are plastic if this
was a plastic rope then
it might work it might go through but
obviously like a hemp rope or a cotton
rope or something it's gonna take
especially a rope that thick i don't
think you're gonna burn through that
very easily
i think i can get these ropes up
come on that was the only part of this
escape to me that kind of looked
legitimate is his hands were tied with a
rope if they were tied legitimately
around uh cinched up to my hands it
would take you some time to get out it's
not physically impossible
you've got to kind of deform your hand a
little bit crush it down get it closer
together you know you're going to get
some rope burns from it if somebody is
going to tie your wrist with a rope
a good tip is how could i demonstrate
this imagine this is a rope imagine if
that's put round my wrists like this
okay a good tip is that somebody's
coming in to tie my wrist is to just
bring the pinky in like this and grab an
extra bit
because if this now goes round and is
locked on top of my hands if i just let
that go
i've got enough slack to get my hand out
look at the rope the rope's like this
thick
it is difficult to tie a thicker rope as
tight as it is a thin rope the chances
of getting out of that kind of rope are
going to be a lot better than getting
out of a smaller rope because it's it's
around the thickest part of his leg here
so if it's around the thickest part of
your leg it can go over the thinnest
part not like if a rope's tied here
around the thinnest part it can't go
over the thickest part of your hand
right i actually might have to give it a
one
because i i really think they could have
done
a lot more homework to make it look a
lot more realistic
if ever you're in a situation like this
right heaven forbid
you you've got to assess the situation
around you first
so for example here
the immediate thought is to try and get
that zip tie off but maybe the radiator
is loose and maybe the paper that's up
there is held up by drawing pins and he
could pull one out and use that to cut
the zip i think what i'd be looking for
in this situation is maybe something
that
i could put through that i could turn
that's going to put a lot of pressure on
the wrist but at some point something
has to give
it is possible using a technique to get
zip ties off this one is slightly
different because his hands aren't zip
tied together is zip tied to the
radiator these aren't what law
enforcement would use it's pretty small
it sounds weird but the zip ties got to
be as tight as it can if you look at my
chest
and my body and look at my arms they're
wider than this zip tie right
so if i were to bring these hands down
against my chest here
with force and with conviction and as i
come to here i kind of push my shoulder
blades at the back i push them together
it'll just snap the zip tie i personally
would never get out of a zip tie like
that but having said that he has
attached the radiator so i don't know
that force would work i'm maybe gonna
give it a six
[Music]
picking a lock is not easy people ask me
how i learned to pick locks this is a
practice lock you can see it's clear
so you can see the pins inside because
essentially when a key goes in lock it
just moves all those little indentations
in the key move the pins into the right
correct format and then it will open the
lock right so
if i wanted to pick this lock you need a
pick and you need a pry bar because a
pry bar puts pressure on the lock as you
pick it so that when you get the pins in
the right place it opens that is exactly
what she's doing there now whether or
not
it looks like she used using a hairpin
or maybe two hairpins whether or not the
hairpin would be strong enough as a pry
bar to put pressure on the lock
essentially the technique she's using
there to open that lock
is is is legitimate
she's pulling it along the pins to try
and rake him into the right position and
what happens is by putting that pressure
on as soon as the pin goes into the
right position it holds and then you go
in you rake another one holds and that
that's always moving until click it goes
i would actually give this a rating of
like 8 out of 10. the only reason i
wouldn't give it a 10 is because i don't
know
if those tools would do that job but
she's certainly using them in the right
way in the techniques right
they're putting leg cuffs on chains
locks i mean this is all pretty standard
fare those cuffs look strong the chains
are good strong chain padlocks
[Music]
first of all if we stop that you notice
she was standing on a platform and then
the platform released and she drops in i
would never do it that way because i'd
be worried uh about cracking my head or
something like that so i use a tank
that's 10 feet high about that height
but very narrow and so what i do is
climb a ladder all chained up and then
kind of inch myself to the edge and get
down into the water on my elbows so that
when i do go under
i i've not got a chance of like hitting
my head
now okay stop she's using nothing to
pick those she's not using there's
nothing i can't see anything she's not
using a lockpick she's she's just
pulling at them and then they come off
houdini when he used to do the
underwater escape they would stand by
the sledgehammer to break the glass when
i was in new york getting ready to
perform on broadway and i had an
accident and i blacked out and i drowned
it was quicker for them to shatter the
tank with a sledgehammer than it was to
use a key what he's using there is like
a bar i don't think that's going to do
the job because that glass is going to
be really thick
she does hold the breath there for about
a minute i think that's certainly not
out the way the average person can hold
the breath
you know 30 seconds to a minute and a
half 90 seconds if i go in a swimming
pool and i just relax and don't move i
can hold my breath for about four and a
half five minutes because my my heart
rate lowers and it's not burning oxygen
because i'm completely relaxed but if i
go in a tank of water and chain and lock
myself up in front of a thousand people
and they lock the lid you better believe
my heart rate goes so high
and burns my oxygen in like
20 seconds the actual record for holding
breath i believe is about 24 minutes
an actual apnea hold without purging
oxygen just
and holding
for a man is about 11 minutes
but for a lady it's about eight minutes
look how much water is coming out of
that little fish tank that's way too
much water there's a dude up top there
with a big hose and a and a pump or
something so if you're in a venue doing
an underwater escape one of the things
they will always say to you is is the
water going to go over the top because
it's going to wreck the stage it's going
to wreck the cameras the cables you
might have a bit of an overflow for a
dramatic effect but you would never ever
have that much water
this bit's cool because this is the
classic they appear at the back of the
audience behind the judges right is this
legitimate absolutely could it be done
the way they've done it in the show
i don't think so maybe like a four
i guess on a premise of
a performance
take me halfway around
the coffin looks like a magic prop right
nobody nobody's gonna buy
that there's absolutely nothing there's
nothing wrong with this coffin it
doesn't have any trapdoors of any kind i
mean it looks like a magic prop which
you would expect from this show
i will become my dead father's body as i
am lowered into his grave buried alive
is a classic plot in escapes you've got
to get out of the coffin however means
that happens but then you've still got
to get through five or six feet of dirt
and you've got to escape before you get
out the coffin there was a magician joe
burris from the us
who did a a buried alive escape and got
out but then a few years later on
halloween he did another version of it
and died
because what he did was he put five feet
of dirt on top but then he put a foot or
two feet of concrete the poured concrete
well david blaine's was different he was
in a clear box with
a clear glass i think on top so people
could see him so there wasn't any chance
of something collapsing keep it together
buster and spin this back around oh my
god the card
this is why
we have this wrap this is what all this
beard and wax and all these tattoos he's
trying to dispel is that myth that we're
all we're all kids party magicians and
hacks i mean would you hire me for your
kid's party i don't think so buster is
uh
the perfect assistant for this although
i don't think the character means for it
to go wrong you very rarely see my
assistants my assistants are in the
wings
making sure that i don't die so people
don't know cpr people have got extra
keys if something goes wrong
sledgehammers
medics things like that and we've had to
use them i mean for escape you'd have to
give it a one
but for comedy value you'd have to give
it a a 15 or a 20 out of 10.
can you confirm that the straps are
tight
the way he's got the straight jacket on
right now is not a way that any escape
artist would ever wear a straight jacket
that the arms have to be crossed with
each wrist under the elbow right so that
when it's tightened up on the back there
is no way you can physically get the arm
over the elbow
you know what i'm not saying escape
bodies don't maybe high key i know
houdini people said he hate keys and
things around
um i would never put a key in my mouth
um mainly because when i'm physically
moving it'd be very easy for me to
swallow that key and choke on the thing
whether it's an extra key or or
if you're using a lot pick an extra lock
pick you've got to have an out when i
was on britain's got talent i dropped a
lockpick while i was trying to get out
of a head tank full of water and i had
to use the bar to break the lot
i cannot tell you how i plan to escape
other than by using magic you know
there's a lot of physicalness to getting
out of a straitjacket you've got to
thrash around you know you get cuts you
get bruises
it hurts
i've burnt myself i've bruised myself
i've cut myself that riding around on
the ground is pretty much
you know
how we do it straight jack and escape is
difficult houdini used to do the
straightjacket escape in every city that
he ever did a show at there are tips and
tricks that we use to try and make that
job a little easier but people have
dislocated limbs and broken limbs and
and all kinds of things trying to do it
so is it true that if you can't get out
you don't want anyone to help you i will
get out oh yes i will not accepting help
if you get stuck um is not the way a
professional escape artist does things i
always have a team on standby and i've
had to use him more than once i've
drowned twice i'm giving him a two
because he's in the straitjacket and
he's put chains on but i mean you know
he's not even wearing the straight
jacket right
maybe a magic word or two
and then i'll be gone one of the first
tricks i ever got shown when i was a kid
was something like that where he's doing
the ball thing right so he's he's going
one
two and like this and it's gone now look
how his hand is he's holding the ball
but it's classic misdirection because if
i just go if i go like this and and
don't look up at it when i when i put it
in this hand you see me put it there but
if my eyes are following the object
that means your eyes are following the
object distraction for something like
this 100
important
that quick without the guard feeling
that
i would say is now impossible maybe if
you set off a firecracker you know or a
bomb it might have worked but just
dropping a ball and me going for it
that switch that quick pretty much
impossible considering that these are
real changed real padlocks but if you
look at the cuff on his right wrist
there
there's actually no padlock in this it's
essentially a key that goes in turns and
it's all built into the into the actual
cuff so these are an old style cuff so
the leg irons here are all built into
the leg iron so he's got to unlock the
iron and then put it around the other
guy when he puts it around the other guy
it will instantly lock when he squeezes
it together so actually it wouldn't take
as much time as i initially thought i
still don't think he's got enough time i
i'm gonna say maybe a five as long as he
picked it here and opened it he could
snap it around the other person
i've done a lot of escapes where i'm
hanging upside down i've never done
escapes the right way up it looks like
she's maybe tied by the wrists with rope
or handcuffs or something
that's hooked up i couldn't lift up a
bag of sugar um never mind a a six foot
two bald headed muscley guy
okay i mean
i listen have you ever tried to get a
key in your front door lock when you
come home and it's nigh on impossible
that kind of position
to then even lift your legs
is really hard unless you have really
good core muscles so i have to use my
hands against my legs to kind of walk
myself up there i'd maybe give this a
five i'm i'm going to say my favorite
escape
in a movie or tv would have to be
something called the water cube trap
which was actually in the saw
series of horror movies and essentially
it was a little cube and when the guy
woke up his head was in this cube there
was two pipes coming in attached to
water uh gallon cylinders and then the
water started coming in and filling up
slowly right i had a very very similar
looking device which was a box attached
to a metal straight jacket hanging from
chains
and
i was all padlocked and chained in and
then they filled it with water and
locked the box
hey thanks so much for watching guys i'm
matt johnson and if you want to watch
other videos like this make sure you go
ahead and click right here